special night for the hall of fame
manager
it will be the first game he has ever
managed against
the saint louis cardinals
congratulations to joe west he is on
track to break hall of famer bill
clinton's
record most regular season games by an
umpire he
ties the record tonight assuming we get
this in
and we will it's our old buddy lance
lynn who was drafted by the cardinals
first round in 2008 debuted with st
louis in 2011.
he's throwing a fastball about 94
of the time so buckle up for the
fastball
he'll face tommy edmond who has a
five-game hitting streak
edmond in the air middle of the diamond
tim anderson with a backup from garcia
and one gone last land we'll go after
dylan carlson
pushed him a fastball and carlson hits
it skyward third base side moncada a
long run
and he gets there to make the catch a
sprinting play by johan monkatta and two
gone
that brings up goldschmidt and goldie
pops it up
right at the plate yasvani grandahl
didn't have to go much of anywhere to
put away out number three
that was a 10 pitch six
strike top of the first for lynn
kwanghan kim retired nine of the first
10 he saw
back on the 16th of may that was a
sunday game against the padres
unraveled in that fourth inning he'll
work to anderson
the o2 pitch and a swing and a miss a
strikeout for kim to start his night
and a good start for kim tonight eaton
sends one to left field moving back on
it under it thomas
he's on the track and makes the catch
two down here comes mankato
kim's pitch is grounded to the shortstop
a chest high bounce for
mundo sosa the throws out mankato each
pitcher worked a one two three first
runner and scoring position for harrison
vader and harrison has a two two-ball
two-strike count
swing and a miss for strike three and
the cardinals strand to man in scoring
position
the lead off batter is jose abreu and
this guy is a handful
here's an o2 pitch to abreu and a swing
and a miss
and strikeout number two i'm very
interested in what mercedes versus kim
is going to look like
should look like a line drive this is a
line drive to center field good call
one out base hit four mercedes here's
grand all batting right-handed
there's a strike on the outside corner
oh there it is
a really delayed call by nick lintz
and then grand is out that's three
strikeouts for kim
andrew vaughn is the batter that ball is
lit up into left field
vaughn rides it to left and mercedes
chugs for third the throw is not in time
and andrew behind the play
gets himself to second base this kid can
hit
two in scoring position with two outs
for garcia here's a ball rake to third
arnado has it
strong throw just got him garcia runs
well but he's out 5-3
leaving two men on so sosa now in
scoring position
and here is carlson another ball in the
air
left center vaughn makes the catch
and that'll do it lead off hit by pitch
no damage done
ninth place hitter nick madrigal and i'm
told this guy almost never
i mean almost never swings and misses he
is a contact guy
madrigal just throws the wand at the
ball and drops it towards center and
fader can't make the play
madrigal guns it for second base and he
is there and vader's hurt
harrison bader is down in center field
and he's significantly hurt
he was writhing in pain when he went
down on that dive
and the cardinals tremendous center
fielder is going to be checked on by
mike schilt out of the dugout
it looks like maybe it's the ball that
he rolled over into the rib cage area
and he is coming out of this game laid
off double still standing
second base see if johan
can step up and deliver hits that ball
hard
left center field long run for carlson
he dives and he makes the play
a sliding play by dylan carlson in
center
for out number three bader's out but
carlson
in his place just shined on that one
so it's up to larry garcia once again he
had two on and two out in the second
he'll have two on and two out
in the fourth 3-2 pitch swung out of
nasty got him with a change up
and strikeout number four for kwan young
kim
is not allowed to hit he's walked two
here's lane thomas
that was the cutter and it's flipped to
right field
eaton is there 5-0 hit for lance lynn
tonight
why not we haven't had one in a week
that's been brilliant yeah no hits so
far for the cardinals in the game
and lin will face the top of the order
now for saint louis
tommy edmond so the inning started with
a walk by tommy edmond
stole second base carlson a deep fly
ball allowing edmond to tag
up now it's a runner at third one out
we're scoreless and the cardinals
chance to take the lead without a base
hit and now you got to deal with
one of their top of the line hitters in
a situation where
you have to bring the infield in white
sox have never had
two no hitters in the same season the
one-two
and goldschmidt picks up the base hit
into left
tommy edmond will score one-nothing
cardinals on a rocket off the bat at
goldsmith and it's ruled a base hit and
the cardinals have a one-nothing lead
i'm just going to say that's a terrible
call by the official scorer
so kim indeed staying in the game daniel
ponce de leon just standing on the mound
in the saint louis pole pen he's at the
96 pitch mark
and look you get a manager understanding
his pitcher however
you got a guy up in vaughan who's hit
the ball hard a couple of times
this becomes a gamble when you don't go
to the right
[Applause]
and it was a gamble by mike chilt and he
lost the gamble
two on for the socks and tim anderson's
going to bat in the sixth
right field third ball into the corner
it goes let it kick around
garcia's home madrigal follows
tim's on his way to third it is
the third out of the inning but a 4-1
lead for the sox
and lance lynn for the white sox still
pitching in this game
as we move to the seventh did you expect
anything
else undergoes grandahl's throw to
second is there
out at second base and the cardinals are
done
in the seventh runners at the quarters
only one out sox looking for more
mercedes hits it in the air to right
field
williams is underneath eaton's ready to
tag here comes adam on his way to the
plate he is down
an in and a 5-1 lead sac fly mercedes
and the cardinals are down to their last
out with sosa coming up
on the ground madrigal nick waits
and delivers the final out of a home
stand
opening 5-1 sox win